Hey Youtubers this is Charlie!
So Marvel has just announced that they're developing a spin-off TV-series for Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
That might even debut by this fall.
So I'll explain what they said, how it's supposed to work and what I think those TV-shows are gonna turn into
So what they said is that the spinoff show will draw from material developed in the back half of Agents Of S.H.I.E.L.D. season 2
So all that stuff that is happening with the inhumans is probably what is gonna lead up into the spinoff
That doesn't mean that it is inclusively going to be an inhumans show
But don't be suprised that they announced the title is inhumans
I mean
talk about brand awereness
In the simplest of terms
ABC and Marvel are just doing the exact same thing that Arrow did when they span off The Flash
What happened is that they had Barry Allen
They brought him on and like in a special two-part episode
And then used that as like a litmus test
To show the network
To say that : 'hey we wanna develop a spin-off show'
The network liked it so much that they said: 'okay go ahead and do a separate pilot'
The rest is history
The Flash ended up being CW's biggest hit of all time
Marvel wants to exploit more of their IP
ABC wants more popular shows
So naturally they're just gonna try and mine the most interesting things that they can
Right now that's inhumans
Just you know, big root from the comics that hasn't been explored a lot on TV and in the movies
What about timing, you know, when is this show supposed to air?
What they've said so far is that the plan is
is that they would premier in the fall
As soon as fall
That doesn't mean that'll end up happening
They might end up pushing it
But for all intends and purposes just expect it to air alongside Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. in the fall
Just like The Flash and Arrow air on different nights
I know a lot of you are asking what does this mean about Agent Carter
Because Agent Carter was like their other show
They haven't said anything about it
But they just made all these big plans for another spin-off show
It doesn't mean that it's cancelled
Agent Carter is still like unofficialy getting a season 2
Typically May is when networks make their final decisions about which new shows they're picking up
And which shows they're cancelling
One of the issues I think Agent Carter runs into
Is that it's more about characters and less about spectacle
And typically what brings in like big eyeballs all across the world
is the spectacle part
The show itself is amazing
Agent Carter is great
But Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. on the other side of that coin
Provides more oppurtunities for big spectacles
and really personal character moments
The same thing happened with Arrow
Whenever they first started making that show
It was supposed to be really dark and griddy
No superpowers
So, like the spectacle level was turned way way down
A couple years later
Barry Allen, superpowered individual debuts on TV
Everyone loves it
And networks realized: 'oh we can do these crazy superpowers'
And people will watch it, people really enjoy this
So I feel like this is Marvel and ABC responding to people wanting to see, you know, powers versus powers
As opposed to regulars versus powers
What about the cast though?
I know everyone is asking like: does that mean the characters from Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. will transition to the new show?
No, I think it'll be just like Arrow and The Flash
The Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. cast will stay on Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
What will happen is:
They'll bring in like a new big character that they think can lead the spin-off show
And then they will build that show around them
Then you have characters like Sky, inhumans with powers that can jump back and forth between shows
And obviously Phill Coulson is always gonna jump back and forth between all the shows and all the movies
There is even a rumor that Coulson is gonna be the one on the Netflix shows to assemble the Defenders
To like go to Daredevil, Jessica Jones, Luke Cage and Iron Fist and say: 'hey, I'm putting a team together
So if you haven't been watching them I recommend you check out Arrow and The Flash
Just to see how the characters bounce back and forth between those shows
Cause I think Marvel and ABC are going to do the exact same thing
Of all the possible names the could give the spin-off show
There's Secret Warriors and Inhumans at the top of the list
It just it depends on how on the nose they wanna be
Because there's gonna be an Inhumans movie
So, I don't know necesarilly if they want a movie with the same name as a TV-show
Although there is a Flash TV-show and there is going to be a Flash movie
It really just depends on how they wanna portray all these inhuman people
And whether or not they are gonna do something like Terrigen bomb
And introduce a hole bunch of new Inhumans
That would have to come after an event on the magnitude of S.H.I.E.L.D. coming down during Captain America: The Winter Solidier
We really have no idea what Marvel is gonna do to develop Inhumans inside the movie universe
Before the Inhumans movie
We've only seen them on TV so far
They could do Terrigen Bomb
Or they could just like slowly tease them out
If you're not familiar with the Terrigen Bomb
A couple of years ago in the comics
Black Bolt dropped a Terrigen Bomb on the Earth, creating thousands and thousands of  new Inhumans, all at the same time
That was actually what lead to the creation of the new Kamala Khan,Miss Marvel
Wouldn't that be awesome if she was on the new spin-off show? That would be badass
So here's my big question for you guys:
Who do you wanna see on this new spin-off show
And: Do you think they're gonna call it Inhumans?
I'll say at the top of my list what I'd really like to see is
a version of runaways with inhumans
like, they're pushing inhumans so hard right now, that they have to involved in someway
But runaways just feels like a really fun show
Something they can use to balance out the seriousness, that you see on S.H.I.E.L.D. every week
There is a lot of funny stuff on S.H.I.E.L.D., but it is a very dark show
So I think it would be fun if they had their version of the Flash
A show that could be about powers versus powers
And have a little bit more fun with itself
In related news I know everyone's asking: when are the Daredevil episodes gonna drop?
Midnight tonight, as I'm posting this video on Thursday. Midnight Thursday Pacific Time, is when everything is coming.
What I'll probably do is post my first spoilery easter-egg video.
Probably like early Friday some time
So be sure to subscribe to get that.
Don't worry if you don't get Netflix, you can't get Netflix.
Eventually they will release the show on DVD
But really, I would recommend you do anything you can to watch it as soon as possible
Do not wait
It is so much fun, you guys have no idea
I'm also working on a Game of Thrones super-recap
From like everything from season 1 to season 4 for like people who aren't caught up
So I'll try and post that tonight
So lots of Daredevil, lots of Game Of Thrones coming this weekend. It is gonna be so much fun
I hope you guys got some extra sleep this week